- People aren't
backing up their mouth.
People have got big ambitions.
Talk a lot of things, you got
those quotes on Instagram but
you don't put in the work
and I totally agree with you.
And guess what?
That's why I don't feel bad.
Like it's hard to feel bad.
- [Envy] Mhmmm.
And the thing is, look,
I'm not naive to
disadvantages and
things of that nature.
When I say I don't feel bad I'm
sitting here spending ungodly
amounts of time, my time,
that's valuable to me.
Forget about money, family,
a little rest here somewhere.
You know and
I'm putting out content and
I'm answering questions.
And I'm giving it to you.
But if you don't
take it, it's free.
I'm not selling $1,000 e-books.
There's no bullshit $500 course
like some of these other fuckers
on Instagram.
This is free.
- [Envy] Right.
- I'm giving it to you for free.
(hip hop music)